Former First lady Michelle
Obama says she cried for 30 minutes
after she left the White House
for the last time,
calling it, quote,
uncontrollable sobbing.
In her new podcast, The Light Podcast,
after the inauguration
and we know
whose inauguration we were at.
That day was so emotional
on so many different reasons.
We were leaving the home
we had been in
for eight years,
the only home our kids really kn
They remembered Chicago,
but they had spent more time
in the White House than anywhere
So we were saying goodbye to the
and all the people
who helped to raise them.
There were tears.
There was that emotion.
But then to sit on that stage
and watch the the opposite of wh
we represented on display,
there was no diversity.
There was no color on that stage
There was no reflection
of the broader sense of America.
And many people took pictures of
and like, you weren't in a good
No, I was not.
We're back now with our panel.
Natasha, how did you hear that?
I think that I understand,
you know, this this first lady
she remains the most popular fir
So let's get that out there. Rig
And she managed to do that
with such grace and dignity.
Right.
So many attacks on her husband
watching this transfer of power
to a man who called for her
husband's birth certificate.
Think of the insults that she en
and yet again,
she made the White House
a place that was for all America
She opened the door.
She said this was the people's h
So I imagine from many levels,
not just politically,
but as a mother, as she said,
this was an incredible transitio
for her.
And so I understand the tears.
I think a lot of people were at
crying with her. Margaret?
Yeah.
You I have a lot of empathy for
and a lot of sympathy for her,
by the way.
Like she sat on that stage,
kept a straight face.
Guess who didn't?
George H.W. Bush, the former pre
I mean, remember,
he had when he heard
the American carnage line,
he said that was
famously was reported to have sa
that's what, some weird ass. Yea
So, like, you have a lot of symp
for anyone in that position,
but it's also eminently
a very personal transition.
I mean, she raised her children
She lived there.
She she has deep relationships
and meaningful relationships and
that were there.
And you can't take that sort
of personal element away from it
So I have a lot of sympathy for
Jay, how did you sneak in here?
I didn't even introduce you to m
How are you going through the si
What did you do with my dear?
Where's my dear?
Congressman, welcome.
Thank you.
How did you hear
what the first lady said there
in the podcast?
You know, I just was really stru
There's almost a national conver
about what strength looks like r
And for me, you know, for her to
show this vulnerability
for me was such a sign of streng
and of real power.
You know,
there are a lot of folks
who would say, oh, that's a weak
You know, I can
I can imagine the sort of headli
you know, oh,
it's a great way to own the libs
Michelle Obama
was crying for a half an hour.
But I felt that that was so beau
first that she had that experien
and then that she felt able to s
that felt like a really,
really profound strong moment.
And that's very interesting
because it took her a while
to share that.
So it's been a few years.
She's written two books now.
She has this podcast. She's shar
But there was a time in 2017
when she went on some late night
show it off.
It was Jimmy Kimmel or Jimmy Fal
But she she joked about it.
What was I thinking that day?
I said, Bye, Felicia.
Like, she just gave a quip.
And now this seems like be more
possibly authentic.
Well, it's been a few years, rig
And, you know,
I think that some of that
might be just coming for
the wisdom that comes from rage.
But some of it is
that she doesn't have to show
that certain face anymore.
All right.
She's not just the recently ex
first lady of time has passed.
And I feel like there's a space
for her to be even more herself.